present and prepare a coherent defense
planning for the whole northern Europe I
would also mention final point that
Secretary General has followed up on the
initiative by the German Chancellor and
myself some months ago to have NATO
included in the
critic defending and protecting the
critical infrastructure
a link to energy and More in particular
to installations in the North Sea
I believe that NATO can play an
important role in cooperating with
private sector this is an issue for the
Mediterranean for the Atlantic and also
for the North Sea and I am pleased that
the Secretary General responded swiftly
and established the coordination cell at
headquarters at NATO and I hope to see
this reflected also in in Venus
please
promise to God
it's great to see you again it's great
to be back in Oslo and a pleasure to be
the guest of the Norwegian government
last time Norway held a meeting over
NATO foreign ministers you were the host
and thank you for inviting us again and
also for your leadership and personal
commitment to our alliance
Norway makes a valuable contributions to
our shared security Now visual forces
serve in our multinational battle group
in Lithuania
you contribute to our air policing
missions and you play a key role in the
high North
and you host the important exercises as
demonstrated with the visit of the USS
General Ford just now
today in our meeting we addressed
Russia's illegal war against Ukraine
Norway provides significant Aid I
welcome that you have committed to a
five-year assistance program this is
something that really makes a difference
with Military Support as well as
financial and humanitarian assistance
and this is something which we all very
much appreciate
I'm confident that with support of NATO
allies Ukraine can continue to liberate
occupied lands and Prevail as a
sovereign independent nation
and our NATO Summit in business we will
demonstrate our long-term commitment to
Ukraine
the war
has made clear Norway's essential role
as a major energy provider for Europe
and you will not have played a key role
in driving NATO as work on protecting
our critical understate infrastructure
including energy Pipelines
we also discussed the need to invest
more in defense I welcome the commitment
by Norway to reach the two percent
Target by 2026
I expect that when we meet in Vilnius we
will agree a new defense investment
pledge with two percent of GDP for
defense is the floor and not the ceiling
because we need to recognize that two
percent is a minimum to meet the
obligations as a NATO Ally
we also discussed Sweden's accession to
Nato
Sweden will become a member all allies
have invited them to join and their
security is already stronger as a result
I'm in close
um and constant contact with Turkish
authorities to ensure that Sweden
becomes a full member as soon as
possible
it's important for Norway security it is
important for the whole Nordic and
Baltic region and it is important for
NATO
let me also address Kosovo
we strongly condemn the unprovoked
attacks against care for troops in
Northern Kosovo which led to 30
peacekeepers being wounded
such attacks are unacceptable and must
stop
K4 the NATO forces will take all
necessary actions to maintain a safe and
secure environment for all citizens in
Kosovo
and we will continue to act in partially
in line with our United Nations mandate
we have decided to deploy 700 more
troops from the operational Reserve
Force for Western Balkans
and to put an additional Battalion of
Reserve forces on eye redness so they
have also be deployed if needed
these are prudent steps to ensure that
K4 has the forces and capabilities it
needs to fulfill its mandate
violence sets back Kosovo and the entire
region and puts eurodynamic aspirations
at risk
both Krishna and Belgrade must take
concrete steps to de-escalate the
situation refrain from further
irresponsible Behavior
and engage in the EU facilitated
dialogue which is the only way to a
lasting peace so once again thank you so
much Jonas for hosting us and for a very
substantive and fruitful meeting thank
you
thank you then we will do questions in
primary we have time for one question
per media and we will start with nrk
after that Financial Times and please
use the microphone in the back go ahead
foreign
[Music]
uh to Mr skoltenberg uh do you and other
allies need to put more pressure on
Turkey over to ensure the admission of
Sweden and to Nato
the constant the contact with the
Turkish authorities and as of course
spoken several times with the president
on this issue and we have to understand
that um
all hours also to Ikea actually made a
very important decision at the NATO
Summit in Madrid last year to invite
both Finland and Sweden to the home
members Finland has already become a
full member I'm confident that also
Sweden will become a full member and in
the meantime we we have to recognize
also that sweetness and a much stronger
and safer place now because as soon as
they were invited they got the a close
relationship with the NATO through the
inviting status meaning that Sweden is
now integrating into NATO's civilian and
Military structures and it's absolutely
inconceivable that will be any threats
or
attack against Sweden without
NATO reacting and on top of that of
course with Finland it makes also Sweden
also ensure that Sweden is coming in
closing so
we are working on this also with aim to
have a decision by davido's Summit there
are no guarantees but it's absolutely
possible to to reach a solution and
enable
the decision on full membership for
Sweden by the venison
then AP
uh
um
foreign
Norfolk
Management Services
[Music]
AP then vegan David huge Associated
Press for several weeks in the build up
to the elections in Turkey the Sweden's
accession stalled and hasn't seen
progress on the turkey side we've seen
elections now that turkey is not coming
to this meeting are you concerned that
this non-attendance will delay the
protest of the the process and with only
six weeks left what is needed to
actually get Sweden to this Finish Line
in Vilnius what could the United States
maybe do to help this process a lot so
first of all um I know that in many
hours of course also not the states are
engaged and uh and uh and and they
agreed to invite the Finland and Sweden
and they also expect that the time has
come to ratify and to foreign
ratification process in other states as
almost all the Allies have rectified
also the accession protocol for uh for
Sweden then it happens quite uh quite
often that not all the ministers are
able to attend the whole ministerial
meetings and as far as I understand
uh there is more the Turkish foreign
political message I think it's
absolutely
for not being able to attend
and what can the United States do to try
and bring this process well well the
United States has all that allies can of
course Express their their View and
their assessment that that Sweden
actually has delivered to her on what
they agreed especially through this
trilateral memorandum that was signed
between Finland and Sweden and turkey
helped sophistic impacted by the
nutritions that happened in Madrid of
the summit and and therefore I think it
is good to understand that
Sweden
as a full member of NATO is good for the
whole Alliance
all allies included in turkey and that's
also has been my my message let me let
me add that at the same time turkey has
legitimate security concerns no other
native allies suffered more terrorist
attacks than than turkey and the fact
that Finland Sweden and also all the
network allies on our are now working
more closely on how to exchange
intelligence information and to work
together in the fight against terrorism
that's something that is important and
we're both Fin and Sweden has has
actually delivered what they promised at
them thank you then Vega and the kind
reminder one question perfectly yeah
foreign
this
is
a TT newsagency Stockholm
um Swedish minister of Foreigner first
basically strong has emphasized that he
wants the question on Swedish expression
to Nato to remain top of the agenda
um how do you intend to make sure that
the question remains at the top of the
agenda and what is there to discuss at
this point given the absence of the
Turkish minister well I mean speaking
for Norway it is on top of our agenda it
has been since Sweden applied since
Sweden was accepted alongside Finland
fulfilling all the criteria this is a
performance-based accession you have to
fulfill criteria we agreed in Madrid
that Sweden fulfilled the criteria and
we are in close dialogue with Stockholm
to support that application all the way
my ambition is still and Norway will
make every effort to have that succeed
in the news I believe six weeks is
absolutely enough to to make that happen
if the will is there and all member
states will be present in Oslo at
representative level so this will
obviously be discussion this is an
informal meeting but at some sometimes
informal meetings are good opportunities
because you can discuss issues in in in
in a good setting so as a member State
as a neighbor as a close friend also we
will work with swin and with other
allies to make that happen
thank you then uh dog brother then AFP
not the borders
[Music]
foreign
yep
um
foreign
the assurances have been given by both
sides in Ankara about a decision and a
positive decision on membership don't
you know anything about those assurances
and and and
how confident are you that this will
happen by July the 11th
because we don't have any certainty and
of course we speak about several
Decisions by uh National parliaments
to to make the decisions on the
ratification uh my message is that it is
Within Reach it's possible to have a
sweetness of all member by the business
Summit because there is a window now
especially after the Turkish elections
and now with the Turkish Parliament
being constituted of course it is
possible and we are working hard for
this to happen as soon as as possible
foreign
[Music]
and today
Mr Secretary General
earlier today you said and I quote it is
completely Unthinkable that NATO would
not react if someone would treat or
attack Sweden even said that a couple of
months ago what did you mean with that
move exactly and the Prime Minister goes
there how involved are you in person in
these discussions with turkey Hungary
and Sweden according to the Swedish
that's what I mean it's exactly what I
said that it is inconceivable that if
there was any effect or attack against
three that NATO will not react that's
partly because Sweden only have a very
strong status NATO because since all
allies security invite Sweden uh Sweden
has integrated more and more closely
into our political and Military
structures
a second several NATO hours including
the biggest ones the United States and
Kingdom Germany France and others have
issued a bilateral Security Services to
Sweden as part of the accession process
then you have Finland as a member you
have the Norway you have in the South
Germany and Poland Denmark so so this
idea that invited Sweden is left alone
is absolutely wrong and as soon as it's
very close to Nato integrating into our
structures
there are there are bilateral security
assurances and NATO has increased its
presence in the region so therefore
we will reactive there was any type of
effect let me then add that we don't see
any imminent risk for anything to attack
against
NATO allies support in Sweden there's
constant risk of course for a different
cyber hybrid attacks but not not high
risk for a full-fledged military attack
if I can add to the Secretary General of
some of the larger NATO States issuing
security messages and guarantees to
Sweden I will also remind that the
Illinois countries did the same thing
Sweden to Sweden Denmark Norway Iceland
upon Sweden's application to both Sweden
and Finland now Finland is a member and
I think for Finland joining that you
know Sweden has friendly Neighbors on
both sides saying that anything
happening to Sweden will not go on you
know unnoticed by Naughty Neighbors on
the work to have this membership secured
my policy has been to take close contact
and advice from the Swedish prime
minister McDonald
Sweden is in the lead of these
discussions in the details they have
variable people managing that process in
coordination with NATO and it has been
our line not to interfere or create any
complications on that road but to take
advice on how we best can support in
terms of atmosphere and input into that
process after that then the last layer
table to Denmark
um
foreign
apartment
thank you so much
that's starting down
[Music]
um
this will be a vet there are a lot um
foreign
[Music]